Hey, Alison, it's Party Bakes Week.
I know. I'm so excited.
I love a good party.
[gasps] Please say
you ordered the bouncy castle.
Of course, I did.
Feast your eyes on this beauty.
Yes, wicked. When can I bounce on it?
I've just gotta inflate it.
[Alison] Oh, okay.
[Noel blowing]
-[blowing]
-How long's this gonna be?
-[chuckles] It'll be ready imminently.
-[sighs]
Welcome to The Great British Baking Show.
-I'll be back in an hour, Noel.
-[blowing]
-[Noel] Now…
-[toots]
-…the quarter-finals…
-Go, go, go.
…means Party Week.
♪ Let's all do the conga
La la la la ♪
[chuckling]
[Noel] The bakers take on
a classic celebration signature…
Being generous with the sausage.
No one wants a small sausage.
…tackle a much-loved
multi-legged technical…
-Think you need to do it again.
-Shut up.
I'm never ever gonna
get this done on time.
…and create a colossal
showstopping spread…
This is the hardest I've worked.
Biscuit Week, I had to do a fair bit.
…worthy of the glitziest celebration.
The ones underneath aren't getting cooked.
How long have we got?
[Noel] So who will be
this week's party pooper?
-Let's hope no one goes too hard too soon.
-[mimics rave whooping]
[Noel] And who will be the tent's
number one party animal?
Bakers, you've had four hours.
This is outrageous.
They're gonna be soggy.
[Tasha] Choux didn't rise. [sighs]
-They're only making one cupcake.
-[laughs]
[opening theme music playing]
[Josh] Here we go again.
Quarter-finals, Party Week.
[Dan] Let's do it, team.
I am buzzing.
I'm so excited.
[Matty] I don't know how I've got here.
I'm full-on thinking, like,
impostor syndrome right now.
It's hard to get my head
around the fact that I'm still here.
To be in the quarter-finals is just
such an honour. I'm made up.
[Dan] Quarter-finals,
there's just no hiding place.
You make an error,
they're gonna pounce on it. Laser focus.
I felt anxious the previous weeks,
this is the first time I've felt nervous.
As soon as you say quarter-final,
it's bigger.
The pressure's on for this week.
Good morning, bakers.
I hope you're all in the mood to celebrate
because it's Party Week today!
Come on, Paul. Let's do the conga.
-[toots]
-[laughter]
No? Okay, your loss.
[Noel laughs]
I think he's more
a "Oops Upside Your Head" guy.
[Alison] I agree.
So for your signature bake,
the judges would like you to make
12 delicious sausage rolls.
The sausage roll,
an absolute staple for any party,
an essential like pass the parcel,
musical chairs or putting your keys
into a bowl at the start of the evening.
[Alison and Dan laugh]
You can use any pastry
that you feel works.
And the filling and the flavour
is completely open
as long as it's shaped into
a sausage wrapped in pastry before baking.
-You have two hours.
-We're gonna be at cake's corner,
doing the "Agadoo".
[Noel] On your marks…
-Get set…
-Bake!
I'm from up north. I love a pastry,
love a sausage roll, so I'm all over it.
[Matty] I don't eat 'em often
if I'm honest.
Don't think the ones
from the shops are nice.
Can't go wrong with a good sausage roll.
I mean, you can in many ways.
It's pastry. [laughs]
So many ways you can go wrong.
It's Party Week, and the signature
challenge is my favourite challenge ever,
sausage rolls.
[Josh] I've practised this at home.
Don't want to say,
"They will be consistent",
'cause that means today,
they're gonna be horrendous.
[Prue] We've said they can make
any pastry they like.
But, I think, most of them
will do a rough puff.
It's a shorter way of doing puff pastry
'cause puff pastry takes hours.
It's hot today in the tent
and butter's gonna melt very quickly.
They'll have to use that fridge,
keep it chilled all the time
up until the moment it's in the oven.
And that will create the lamination,
flake and butteriness that you need
on the exterior of a good sausage roll.
[Matty] Next we go onto
the sausage filling.
When it comes to flavours,
it's gotta pack a punch.
You want that little bit of moisture
in there, don't want it too dry or claggy.
The pastry won't have much flavour to it,
so the filling needs to stand out.
You can't beat a good sausage roll.
I've baked millions of sausage rolls.
So this challenge is something
I'm looking forward to.
-Hiya, Cristy.
-Morning.
Hello, Cristy.
Right, Cristy, tell us all about
your sausage rolls.
[Cristy] My sausage roll is a combination
of Paul's tutorials I've watched.
-Right.
-[Noel] Are they the videos
where he's making a sausage roll
wearing just Speedos?
[laughing] Not seen that one, no.
[Noel] Serving up her take
on Paul's rough puff pastry,
Cristy's party sausage rolls will have
a classic pork and sage and onion filling
with a layer of homemade cranberry sauce.
-Looks like six cloves of garlic.
-[Cristy] Lots of garlic
because I got lots of sausage meat.
I don't want it to taste bland.
-Sounds lovely.
-It does sound a classic one
with the sage stuffing.
Yeah, I like it.
-Look forward to it.
-Okay, great. Thank you.
[Alison] Not everyone is staying true
to the much-loved British classic.
My sausage rolls are inspired
by my love of dim sums,
-so I'm doing a siu mai sausage roll.
-[Paul chuckles]
So we're off to the Far East again.
[laughs] We are. You love it.
-Next you'll say there'll be a soy dip.
-There is.
-Unbelievable.
-[all laugh]
[Alison] Mixing up food cultures,
Dan's dim sum inspired sausage rolls
will have a punchy pork,
prawn, ginger and garlic filling,
with five-spice flavoured
rough puff pastry.
-I do like siu mai.
-Yeah.
However, sausage roll,
one of my all-time favourite foods.
And then you blend them together.
This better be good.
[laughs]
-Thank you.
-[Dan] Cheers.
"Don't let me down."
I know. I'm like his son, aren't I?
[Noel] Josh is also adding ingredients
not usually found
in the humble sausage roll.
[Josh] I haven't put sprouts
in a sausage roll before.
It wouldn't be Christmas
if you didn't have sprouts.
-We're back at Christmas?
-Yes.
-[Prue] Oh.
-We've got Christmas.
Got turkey mince and sausage meat as well,
-'cause the turkey can get dry.
-[Paul] Nice idea.
It's Christmas in a sausage roll,
which can't be a bad thing.
[Noel] Josh's festive sausage rolls
will be filled with pork, turkey,
Brussel sprouts, chestnuts and apricots,
along with a layer of cranberry sauce.
-Josh is bringing the party with his top.
-Gone all Christmassy.
[Alison] How's your sausage rolls?
An easy one, innit?
-There's a lot that can go wrong.
-What?
-And you've got quarter-final nerves.
-Don't be nervous.
That's why I'm here,
to calm you down a bit. Have I?
-Yeah, you have. A lot.
-Oh, job done.
[laughs]
[Alison] If the bakers are to achieve
the flaky laminated layers
the judges expect…
[Cristy] Gonna grate more butter in,
do a little turn.
[Alison] …their dough must get
multiple turns and oodles of butter.
This is frozen butter.
The key is keeping it cold.
Otherwise, the butter melts
and you lose the lamination.
You can see the butter coming through.
You want it cold, but I've got warm hands.
So, you've gotta work
nice and quickly with it.
-[Noel] Do you like making pastry?
-Not as much as Paul.
-[chuckles]
-[laughs]
[Noel] It's such an odd skill.
And you will be the fastest
and you will be the most powerful.
And you will be good at pastry.
-[both laugh]
-[Noel] Such a weird thing, isn't it?
-[Alison] With the sun baking the tent…
-[exhales]
…it's crucial doughs go back in the fridge
while bakers crack on with fillings.
[Tasha] A lot of multitasking today,
because the pastry needs time to chill.
[Alison] ♪ Let's all do the conga
Let's all do the conga ♪
♪ La la la la ♪
-[all laughing]
-♪ La la la la ♪
It's Party Week!
Imagine the party if you win.
-We'll have a party if I lose as well.
-[both laugh]
[Noel] Inspired by picnicking in the park,
Tasha's sausage rolls
will be filled with pork, apple,
and moistened with a layer
of cider, apricot and apple sauce.
Looking forward to this,
gonna taste amazing.
I hope so.
How do you feel about the final now?
Could you think you're in reach?
Whatever happens now, I'm really proud.
-Yeah, but you wanna win, right?
-[Noel and Tasha laugh]
You're talented enough
to get to the final,
it's all about concentrating
on each dish and getting it correct.
So, good luck.
[Alison] Tasha's not
the only quarter-final baker
opting for a fruity flavour.
[Matty] The apples are good in getting
moisture into the sausage rolls.
Can't have a dry sausage roll.
That'd be gross.
[Noel] Matty's tweaking classic pork,
sage and onion sausage roll flavours
by adding grated apple
and a touch of chilli.
It's kind of a play
on pork and apple with stuffing.
Okay.
Good idea. Where are the chilli going?
[Matty] I've put half a teaspoon in
the sausage meat. A little added element.
Hopefully, it works. Fingers crossed.
[Alison] In addition to
punchy flavours in their fillings…
There's some soy sauce, ginger, garlic.
Definitely not traditional, no.
…many of the bakers
are adding a fruit sauce…
[Josh] That is my cranberry sauce.
[Alison] …to complement their meat
and keep the bake moist.
So we have apricot sauce just to give it
a little bit of something different.
[Dan] Give it a good squidge.
Everything's banged in there.
Hello, Dan. Is this sausage roll
gonna bring the party today?
Hopefully so, yes.
What's the best party you've ever been to?
I went to Ibiza when I was 20.
I've finally recovered.
My party now,
I'm in bed by about eight o'clock.
-Me too, you're exactly like me.
-[laughing]
-My party is in my bed.
-Yeah, I like, er, yeah… [laughs]
Bakers, you are halfway through.
That was powerful.
-Thank you.
-[both laugh]
[Tasha] It's time to roll.
Nice and chilled.
[Dan] I'm looking for about 60 centimetres
and then 15 wide.
So I've got enough pastry
to fold it over then hopefully.
[Cristy] It's so cold. [laughs]
It's gone quite stiff.
So I can't have it thick,
'cause it'll just be not nice.
Don't know about you, but I like
a thick pastry on a sausage roll.
[Tasha] The apricot sauce is gonna go on.
This is hot so I'll have to work quickly.
[Cristy] Go, go.
[Dan] Good fun, isn't it?
[Josh] Spread cranberry sauce
on the inside.
A nice bit of sweetness
to cut through that savoury filling.
I'm being generous with the sausage.
No one wants a small sausage.
[Dan] Want a good mouthful, yeah.
I'll give myself enough filling
to have absolutely no excuses.
[Matty] This is the caramelised onions.
[Josh] I like to make them individually.
Helps me keep it uniform.
Just trying to get it sort of
as equal as humanely possible.
[Josh] I'm pleased with the pastry,
looks nice.
[Matty] Right egg wash, sesame seeds,
sage leaf, sea salt
and then hopefully, it looks nice.
[Dan] And we're going in.
[Noel] To prevent the carefully
incorporated butter leaking out,
the sausage rolls must go
into a piping-hot oven
for the first blast of heat
to set the pastry.
[Dan] So I'm doing them
at half an hour at 200 degrees.
We're gonna flip 'em round after
15 minutes so they get an even colour.
They're gonna go in
till pretty much near the end.
-So 40 minutes.
-[timer beeps]
[Tasha] My timer's saying
it's time to hurry up.
[Noel] But not everyone's oven-ready.
-[Tasha] Have to work like the clappers.
-[Cristy] These aren't done.
[Tasha] They are not neat sausages.
Oh, I hope they taste good.
Bakers, you have 30 minutes left.
[Tasha sighs] Flipping heck.
Yeah, they look good.
Yeah, you get a bit of juices
come out of it,
but I love that colour you get
around the edge and on the bottom.
-[Noel] How are they looking?
-[Dan] All right, pretty groovy.
Paul was quite frightened
that you were putting prawn in.
He'll either
dig his heels in and go, "No."
Or he'll go, "Yeah,
you've actually surprised me there".
You're quite close to the final now.
Very, very weird. Yeah.
Who do you think?
Josh.
Yeah, I've had my eye on him
since about week three.
Your card's marked sunshine.
[Noel] You know what it's like.
-They're your friends, but ultimately--
-Wanna take 'em down.
-Gonna crush you. [laughing]
-Yeah.
[Tasha] They're puffing up.
I'm just debating
when to change the racks round.
[Matty] They're all right, to be fair.
Not far off being done.
[Josh] One tray, one shelf now,
so I can get a nice even colour.
[Tasha] The sausage meat is squeezing out.
[Cristy] They're all soggy at the bottom.
[sighs]
[Matty] This part's horrendous.
You second-guess everything.
You don't look at 'em
and think, "They look nice".
You think, "What are they gonna say?"
The ones underneath aren't getting cooked.
How long have we got?
Bakers, you have five minutes left.
[Tasha sighs] Oh, my God.
I'm gonna take 'em out now.
[oven beeps]
[Alison] For Paul's most beloved bake,
the judges expect nothing less
than mouthwatering delicious fillings…
Could do with more colour.
[Cristy] They look cooked,
but I want 'em to get dark.
[Alison] …and delectably rich,
tender pastry.
[Dan] Holy mackerel. Nuclear, them.
-[Josh] Yep, all good, look great.
-[Matty] They look all right, to be fair.
[Dan] Done 'em
for five minutes longer.
-Just thought an extra bit of browning.
-They can come out.
They're gonna be soggy.
[Tasha] Not the prettiest things.
They don't look good.
[Tasha] They might taste amazing,
just be ugly on the outside.
[Cristy] Oh, my gosh.
Bakers, that is your time
on your signature.
Step away from your sausage rolls.
And if you've got any scraps for me,
I love munching on a sausage.
Can't wait to get involved
in Dan's sausage.
Oh, me too. [laughs]
[laughs]
[Noel] The bakers' party sausage rolls
now face the judgement of Paul and Prue.
-Hello, Tasha.
-Hi, Tash.
I do think they look good.
You can see the lamination, beautiful.
You obviously made
some very good pastry dough,
but you just ran out of time
somewhere along the line.
They needed longer in the oven.
Mmm. I love that.
Thank you.
Flavour is superb. The apricot works
beautifully well with it.
-Lovely.
-The only issue is the bake.
Too soggy. Needed another ten minutes
to make that flaky and beautiful.
But your filling is exceptional.
Pop them in the oven for ten minutes,
have 'em for lunch.
I'll switch it on now.
[Paul] Like the colour,
they do look all right with those seeds.
They look good.
-[Paul] Nice bit of flake there.
-[Prue] So it's prawns and pork?
-Yeah.
-[Paul] Hmm.
[Prue] It certainly tastes Chinese.
Erm, I'm not keen on the flavour.
-Not my favourite.
-Okay. Yeah.
The flavours are delicious.
I'm not used to them in a sausage roll.
Yeah. Anything's allowed in pastry.
-But not a sausage roll.
-[Prue and Dan laughing]
[laughs]
[Paul] Thank you.
Ah, cheers, thank you. Nice one.
Win some, you lose some.
I can see a bit of lamination there.
[Paul] But with a laminated dough,
you expect that lamination to grow
so you don't end up with gaps.
These are very gappy.
It needed longer in the oven.
[Prue] Does it taste like Christmas?
It's got the sharpness from the cranberry.
Bit dry, the sausage meat. Quite solid.
It is a tiny bit dry,
but I think the flavour is terrific.
And I like the texture.
But if the pastry was a little more baked,
it'd be perfect.
-[Paul] Thanks.
-Thanks.
-[Paul] Happy with them?
-No, at home they got darker.
[Paul] They do look pale.
-Yeah, got a bit of a soggy bottom there.
-Yeah. I'm so sorry.
They smell good.
-They are a little underbaked.
-They are.
I quite like the flavour. Flavour's good,
well-balanced, well-seasoned.
The pastry is your weak link.
-It comes down to the baking.
-Yeah.
I think that that filling
is absolutely perfect.
The sharpness you get
from the cranberry is delicious.
But I agree about the pastry,
underbaked and too thick.
I love the shape of them.
They're nice and round.
[Paul] Couple of things I like.
One, I like the colour.
You got a nice, strong bake underneath.
But you see the layers here.
The lamination.
-[Alison] Yeah.
-[Paul] That's a good sign.
-Thanks.
-[Paul] They look very nice.
Ooh, nice crisp.
-Nice bit of kick there from the chilli.
-Little bit of chilli flakes, yeah.
-[Matty gasps]
-[Alison] Ah!
-Thank you for bringing me a sausage roll.
-[laughs]
-[Prue] A very good sausage roll.
-Delicious.
The onions really work,
the apple really works,
-the chilli is great.
-[Prue] It's really good.
Thank you, Matthew.
[laughs]
That went well.
I never thought about getting a handshake.
It kind of took me by surprise.
I'm pretty happy with that.
Happy with that. I fully expected worse.
I knew that they needed baking longer.
Bit of a mixed bag,
but you know, I've taken a few risks.
Some pay off, some don't. Prue liked 'em.
[Noel] Next up, the bakers have no idea
what they'll be asked to make
in the mystery
that is the technical challenge.
Welcome back for your technical challenge
set by the life and soul
of any good shindig,
it's Paul Hollywood.
[Noel] Paul, any trinkets,
nuggets or words of wisdom?
You'll all know this for sure.
It's a very, very famous bake.
So just read the recipe carefully
and enjoy it.
[laughs]
[Alison] Paul and Prue
are gonna take a little timeout
before they get over-excitable
and start showing off.
-Thank you, guys.
-[Noel laughs]
[Alison] Bye-bye.
Paul would love you to make
a chocolate caterpillar cake.
[contestants chuckling]
So your caterpillar should be made
of a chocolate Swiss roll sponge
filled with a chocolate
meringue buttercream
and then coated in a silky-smooth ganache.
Not forgetting the chocolate
and meringue features
that will bring your caterpillar to life.
You only have
two and a half hours for this.
We were gonna give you three hours,
but we didn't want your caterpillars
to metamorphosise into butterflies.
-[laughs]
-On your marks…
-Get set…
-Bake!
A staple of any birthday in our house.
Yes, even my own.
[laughing] Never made one though.
Had a few varieties from a few shops.
We've got 16 steps.
There's a lot of components to this one.
So, Paul, the famous caterpillar cake.
[chuckles] It's a terrific challenge.
It's a Swiss roll sponge
which they've all done many times.
The trick is getting the bake right.
Overbaking it by a minute,
it'll be bone dry.
What's important is to create the ridges.
We've explained how
and where to cut the strips,
and it creates these bumps
all the way along.
Inside, they have
the Swiss meringue buttercream.
On top of that
they've gotta put a ganache.
The decoration is where they can have
a bit of artistic flair. Have fun with it.
-All kids love that at a birthday party.
-I quite like it too, give me a bit.
[Paul] There you go.
It's the right proportion
of buttercream to cake,
and that looks like really light cake.
The ganache with the buttercream
with that chocolate sponge,
-it's three hits of chocolate.
-It's lovely.
On my birthday, Prue,
make me a caterpillar cake.
-[chuckles] Okay.
-[laughs]
Step one, "Make a chocolate
Swiss roll sponge."
[Cristy] Whipped up my eggs and sugar,
and I'm gonna fold through
the cocoa powder and flour
to try and keep
as much air in as possible.
[Alison] For the light,
delicate bake the judges expect…
Don't wanna get any lumps
or knock the air out.
…ingredients must be gently combined.
Overmix, and the baker's sponge
will be dense.
-[Tasha] Happy with that.
-[Alison] You familiar with this cake?
Is there anyone
who doesn't know this cake?
[Alison] It's one of my favourite cakes.
-Yeah.
-[Alison] Can you believe
that you've got to the semifinals?
-Sorry, it's not the semifinals.
-[laughs]
That's a bit awks.
Er, I'm rushing the show on.
That's really awkward.
Can you believe you won? [laughs]
-How does it feel?
-Thank you, everyone.
-[Cristy] Get it in to bake.
-[Dan] See you in a bit.
It doesn't give us
a bake time as per usual.
They bake very quickly, er, Swiss rolls,
so not gonna bake it for too long.
Try for ten.
See how it looks.
Twelve minutes, gonna check it.
Next one is to make
the, er, batch of Swiss meringue.
I've not done a Swiss meringue
for a long time.
So I'll look over my shoulder
and copy what someone else is doing.
[laughs]
When you're making Swiss meringue,
you are whisking sugar and egg white
together over a bain-marie.
[singsong] Piece of cake
when someone else is doing it…
[normally] …and you can steal it off them.
How'd it go before?
Did they like yours?
-[Dan] No.
-[Noel] Why? It had prawn?
[Dan] Was a bit dry.
You've gotta make this count.
I have got to.
Anything out the top three,
you're in trouble.
[Noel] ♪ No room for error ♪
♪ There's not at all ♪
I can see that it's starting
to get a lot thicker now.
Must be done,
'cause it's got no sugar grains
and it's holding stiff peaks.
[Tasha] Happy with that.
Add butter to meringue into the bowl.
Now I just need to fold in the chocolate.
Should be delicious.
[Dan] That is flipping lovely.
Quickly just check my sponge.
[Cristy] Feel like that's done.
[Tasha] Yeah, I'm happy with that.
That's looking all right.
[Dan] Cake's all cracked.
A bit of a bummer.
Hopefully it'll be all right.
Bakers, you are halfway through.
[Cristy] I'm gonna colour
the Swiss meringue.
"Divide between three small bowls."
"Colour one green, red and yellow."
[Dan] That's a lovely red colour.
[Tasha] How green are we going?
It's a birthday party, it's really green.
"Pipe small seven
meringue kisses of each colour."
These are gonna be
for the top of the caterpillar.
And then you've got to pipe legs.
[Tasha] And then green antenna.
Swiss meringue,
how long's that gonna bake for?
[oven beeps]
Meringue takes a long time, low and slow.
[Alison] Get 'em in, babes.
You're familiar
with caterpillar cakes, right?
I've eaten 'em,
but I've eaten loads of stuff,
and couldn't tell you
how to make most of it.
[Tasha] I am gonna do the face.
"Melt white chocolate,
pour into the lined cutter."
[Cristy] I'm gonna let it set,
then put its little features on.
You could have it as me, create my face.
-Shall I try?
-On your caterpillar.
-I'd probably do you an injustice.
-[both laugh]
Bakers, you have half an hour left.
Come on, guys, this is serious.
"To create the ridges on the caterpillar,
cut strips out of a sponge."
"Make 13 cuts, 1.5 centimetres apart."
You've gotta bite the bullet
and go for it.
[Dan] All right.
[Tasha] There we go.
[Dan] Isn't gonna be that way,
it's gonna be that way.
Like a flipping dog's dinner, this sponge.
[Cristy] Like that.
"Remove seven
of the fingers of the sponge."
Five.
"Spread the buttercream over sponge
and re-roll from the non-ridge end."
What's the non-ridge end?
Have I gone the right way here?
Should have gone that way, shouldn't I?
You doughnut.
[Cristy] I've done it wrong.
I'm remaking it.
[chuckling] I'm gonna try.
Okay, let's go.
[Tasha] Okay,
this is not fiddly in the slightest.
Now we roll.
Just do a bit at a time.
[Matty] Not the prettiest of caterpillars.
[Tasha] Go on, my son.
Oh, yeah. Okay.
So I might as well go
with what I've done now.
-Going in.
-[oven beeps]
Try my best.
[exhales]
Best thing I can do here is cut that off.
A very small caterpillar, isn't it?
Got a swirl. I was expecting
a better shape. What will be, will be.
I think my cake might be a little bit dry,
but we'll move on.
[Dan] Cover it in chocolate
and hope for the best.
Splodge a bit more on, just in case, eh?
Bakers, you have 15 minutes left.
Flipping heck.
Not very long.
[Cristy] That's done.
Make a chocolate ganache to coat the cake.
Heating the cream to the point
where it should melt the chocolate.
[Tasha] Gonna spread it
with my palette knife for control.
[Matty] Fingers crossed
we are hiding a world of sin.
"Create features for the face."
Rosy cheeks may look nice. Ooh!
[Dan] This'll be the best bit of the cake.
This is Noel. [laughs]
How big shall I make the sideburns?
-Massive.
How big do you want your pupils?
-[both laughing]
-Surprise me. Very excited.
-[Josh] It looks fairly cute.
[Matty] Was supposed to be cuter.
[Cristy] Roll it up, still quite warm.
-Get it in that freezer.
-Bakers, you have five minutes left.
[Dan] I can't wait for a pint.
[Cristy] Let it chill for a minute.
There's a squirrel in this freezer.
Not funny. I don't know who did that.
-It's gotta stop.
-[laughs]
Oh, come on.
Ganache, ganache, come on.
What do I do for the face?
[Dan] Now where shall I stick his face?
[Matty] Not the children's party
I was hoping for.
-[Tasha] That's terrifying.
-[Dan] And decorate.
Splodge 'em on everywhere, basically.
[Tasha] Legs.
I forgot to pipe antennas. Idiot.
Bakers, you have one minute left.
-[Dan] Let's move it.
-[Cristy] Get the meringues on.
-Think you need to do it again.
-Shut up.
[Josh] I need to put the soil
around it now.
[Cristy] Soil it all up.
-Move, move, move, move.
-[Cristy] Dan, can I use your crumbs?
-Do you need any more?
-No.
-Do you want some of this?
-Yes. Anything.
-Go for it. Stick that there.
-I'm not allowed to help you.
-[Cristy] Okay.
-[Tasha] Sorry, Noel, you been done dirty.
[Cristy] He's a bit weird,
but we still love him.
[Dan] He's a beauty.
Bakers, your time is up.
Please bring your caterpillars
down to the gingham table
and place them behind your photographs.
[Cristy] If anyone buys me
one of these for my birthday,
I'm gonna literally be fuming.
I think I made a mistake by doing Noel.
[laughing] He's terrifying.
[Noel] It's judgement time
for the bakers' caterpillar cakes.
[whistles]
[Alison] Paul and Prue are looking
for a light sponge
with a smooth
chocolate buttercream filling,
coated with a shiny ganache,
decorated with meringue features.
As always…
Okay.
…they have no idea whose bake is whose.
[Paul] Shall we start
with this strange looking animal here?
This is unusual.
-Quite a scary-looking face.
-[Prue] It is scary, but it's quite neat.
It's got lots of legs.
[Paul] No antenna. It looks like a train.
Filling doesn't look too bad.
There's a bit of a swirl there.
-[Prue] Lots of buttercream.
-[Paul] Yeah, there is.
The chocolate is nice.
The sponge feels dry though.
I think that's slightly overdone.
Moving on, this seems
slightly all over the place.
Running out of time
could have been a big problem.
The legs are there, no antenna.
This one feels a bit softer
on the sponge.
[Prue] Yeah, and a little less
buttercream, which is good.
The Swiss meringue buttercream
is delicious,
-ganache is good.
-And the cake is good.
[Paul] I don't think it's neat.
Moving on to this one.
Legs are good, antenna is there.
It's got Noel's face on the front.
-[both laughing]
-Erm…
-[Prue] With his tongue stuck out.
-[Paul] Yeah.
[Prue] It's not scary.
Thanks, Prue. Mine or the cake?
[both laughing]
[Paul] I like the decoration.
-It's pretty good.
-[Prue] It's good.
[Paul] It's very light.
-Delicious. Gorgeous.
-A delight for a kids' birthday party.
-Amazing.
-It's delicious.
[Paul] Moving on.
It's a bit short on legs,
this caterpillar.
[Paul] Very much so.
And everything's in place,
it just looks a bit messy.
Ooh.
-Bit drier, that one.
-Cake is bit drier,
-but it's still delicious.
-[Paul] It is lovely.
-This looks a bit of a mess.
-[Prue laughs]
-This is a very skinny caterpillar.
-[Paul] A small one. Look at those legs.
I don't think the baker
understood about how to make the ridges.
[Paul] Yeah, it's very, very small.
At some kid's party,
they'd be a bit disappointed.
It seems to be all
Swiss meringue buttercream than sponge.
Overmixed, overbaked,
either, either or both.
[Prue] Very good face.
[Noel] The caterpillar cakes will now
be ranked from last to first place.
In fifth spot we have… this one.
-That's me.
-[Paul] Dan, not quite sure what this is.
I cut my things the wrong way.
Hence it's small.
In fourth place we have this one. Josh.
Tastes all right.
-But the cake's a bit tough.
-Okay.
In third spot we have this one.
Matty, the sponge was a little bit dry,
but you managed to get
all the elements there.
In second place we have this one.
Who's that?
Cristy, this tastes absolutely delicious,
and it's a beautifully made sponge,
but it doesn't look great.
I had to remake it all,
and rush it, sorry.
And in first spot we have this one.
Tasha, this is pretty good.
You have all the elements in place,
and it's beautifully round.
-That's a decent cake, well done.
-Thank you.
[Prue] Even if it does look like Noel.
[laughing]
First in technical.
Maybe I'll just base everything
on Noel's face from now on.
[Dan] I knew I'd come last.
It's tough working at the front,
can't see what everyone else is doing.
So you can't copy people.
I mean, it was an absolute nightmare.
Never wanna do it again,
but I can't believe it,
I'm so proud of myself.
Party Week,
Matty's definitely bringing the party.
He got a handshake,
those sausage rolls were off the scale.
[Paul] But he was third in technical,
he let himself down.
[Noel] Tasha, won the technical.
Obviously she cheated
by using my face on a caterpillar.
-Obviously she was gonna win…
-[both laugh]
…with your face on it.
It's between Matty and Tash,
who at the moment
are in line for Star Baker.
That leaves Josh, Cristy
and Dan in trouble.
[Prue] I'm so surprised at Dan,
because Dan started off the Star Baker.
Is there anything in the fact
that when you become Star Baker
then the following week you're rubbish?
Oh, darling, it's the curse of Star Baker.
-It's well known.
-It's a real thing.
If they win Star Baker,
next week I turn their ovens off.
[all laughing]
Welcome back, bakers,
to your final challenge of Party Week.
Let's hope no one goes too hard too soon.
-That's true.
-[Noel chuckles]
[both laughing]
-It's my life mantra.
-[both laughing]
[Noel sighing] Ah.
So, for your showstopper challenge,
the judges would like you to create
an incredible Anything But Beige buffet.
[Noel] We don't want beige.
Let's hope none of you
are thinking of serving up
my Auntie June's living room,
which is a hell of a beige room.
[laughs]
Paul and Prue would love you to create
a colourful and highly decorative display
of a mixture of sweet
and savoury party bakes.
You have a whopping four-and-a-half hours
to complete this task.
[Alison] Don't waste it, party people.
[chuckles] We wanna see you twerking.
-On your marks…
-Get set…
Bake!
Stacks of work, not enough time,
living the dream, what can go wrong?
Everything.
[Josh] Biggest challenge
is to get all the components made
and give myself enough time to get
a nice decorative finish.
It's like order of operations.
I'm just gonna try and stay calm.
[Alison] The bakers' tricky task
is to reinvent the buffet's stale image
of beige, bland bakes
by creating colourful
and highly decorative party food.
I am starting off with my bread.
I'm using beetroot, just for colour,
you can't taste it at all.
[Josh] This is gonna be
a couronne, so a bread.
I've got the green colouring
by using some pureed spinach.
We want a mixture of savoury and sweet.
At least 12 of each of them.
We're actually asking them
to do quite a big catering job.
-Four-and-a-half hours is long.
-I did ask for six.
-I got politely turned down.
-[laughs]
[Paul] Multiple baking,
it's about your timetable.
While something's in the oven
or cooling or in the fridge,
you should crack on with something else.
If there's a dead time,
you're doing something wrong.
I'm trying to multitask,
which is far from my forte.
[Paul] Getting close now,
it's semifinals next week,
and I want to see the bakers
really show off what they can do.
But they don't wanna push themselves
too much that they fall off the cliff.
I do think that many great bakers slip up
because they're too ambitious.
You can have the most wonderful vision,
but if you can't make it happen in time,
it's not gonna be worth anything.
[Noel] In this gigantic challenge…
Is that your first book?
Yeah, my first book.
There's only 26 things to do. [laughs]
…Josh and Tasha
are starting with savoury breads…
I'm gonna make a pesto to mix into it,
so you've got some beautiful flavours.
…while Dan, Matty and Cristy
kick off with pastry.
I've got curry powder
and turmeric going in there.
So it'll be bright yellow.
[Dan] That's the shortcrust pastry
for my curry pies.
-[Paul and Prue] Hello.
-Good morning.
-How we doing?
-Hello.
Dan, we need to know about your buffet.
So, I'm doing, er, a prehistoric-themed
Anything But Beige buffet today.
For my savoury element,
I'm doing chicken curry dinosaur feet.
They'll be trotting up
my presentation board.
For my sweet elements,
I'm doing some ankylosaurus tea cakes.
[Dan and Alison laugh]
[Prue] Tell us about them.
[Dan] They had a brain
the size of a walnut,
I'm putting a walnut
on top for decoration
'cause they had armour on.
Two little fondant horns
and a big grumpy face.
[Paul] Clever.
[Alison] Dan's giant Jurassic buffet
features not only
savoury dinosaur feet curry pies
but sweet, lemon shortbread fossils,
ankylosaurus head teacakes,
cake pop stones and white chocolate
dinosaur eggs in chocolate nests.
-[Paul] How many things? Five, six?
-Six.
This is ambitious.
Maybe he'll pull it off.
It's simple elements done really well,
that's what I'm hoping.
-Thank you very much.
-[Dan] Cheers.
I've got a lot to do, it appears,
doesn't it? Yeah. [laughs]
[Noel] While Dan's plan is quantity,
doing half as many bakes,
Josh is prioritising precision.
[Josh] A meticulous schedule today.
It's the quarter-final
so I've planned things down,
every single ingredient is thought through
and has a reason why I did it.
[Noel] Creating his second
Christmas-themed bake of the competition,
Josh's festive buffet
will have sweet white chocolate
and coconut snowman macarons,
choux bun Christmas puddings
with chocolate craquelin.
His savoury bake will be a traditional
French Christmas couronne wreath
with cheese, spinach and pesto.
What do you love about Christmas?
I love themed baking.
Christmas is an easy one,
'cause there's so many Christmas bakes.
There's something elf-like about you.
I've got elf socks I nearly wore today.
It's too hot.
I was gonna have them up here
with red and white…
Put 'em on for the judging. [laughs]
[Alison] When it comes
to their savoury bakes…
It'll be spicy,
a little bit of a kick to it.
…the bakers need to ensure
they deliver not only on colour
but delicious flavour.
I'm putting Madras curry powder in.
Goes really nice with the coconut milk.
[Alison] More than one baker's
embracing Indian flavours.
[Matty] We've got curry powder, fenugreek,
I guess it's like a take on a balti,
but I don't wanna call it that,
in case I've not quite hit the brief.
If I call it curry, it's open-ended.
[Noel] PE teacher Matty's going sporty
with curry-filled colourful
cricket ball pies,
basketball crème brûlée doughnuts,
green tennis ball macarons
and a golf course
of chocolate and orange cupcakes.
Oh, this is the party I wanna be at.
Pies, cupcakes, doughnuts.
Is this the sort of buffet you'd put on
for your kids at school?
-No.
-No. [laughs]
I'd have a buffet all day long,
a Chinese buffet.
-Oh, yeah.
-Oh, come on.
[Noel] If the bakers are to deliver
the kind of spread the judges expect,
it means juggling
both savoury bakes and sweet.
This is pistachio and raspberry
Viennese biscuit. Pretty strong flavours.
That is just fossil biscuits.
Trilobites and ammonites.
The flavours are chocolate and orange
which is hopefully gonna be quite nice.
[Noel] Also going big on chocolate…
[Cristy] Making my Swiss roll.
[Noel] …Cristy's celebrating
a king of confectionery.
The theme's Willy Wonka.
When I was a child,
that was my favourite film,
so, yeah, hopefully I'll do it justice.
[Alison] Full of innovation,
Cristy's marvellous sweet factory buffet
will have pink chocolate
Swiss roll lollipops
and lemon meringue cupcakes
topped with toadstools.
Her savoury bake continues the theme
with candy cane-style cheese twists
and spiced beef and onion patties
shaped as sweets.
It'll be a thing that twists your brain.
-It looks sweet, and it'll be savoury.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, that sort of thing.
-I like the sound of this.
I've practised loads, but God knows
what'll happen. Hopefully, it'll be good.
-[Paul] Thank you.
-Thank you.
[Alison] With one hour gone,
a batch of sweet bakes
are the first to hit the oven…
170 for 20 minutes.
…and the bakers are on to assembling
their savoury breads and pastries.
[Dan] Putting my dinosaur feet together.
They're like canapes really.
Just bite-size trinkets.
This is the beef and onion filling
for the pastries.
[Matty] The pies are red
'cause they'll be cricket balls.
I'm hoping that it dies down a bit,
it's quite vibrant at the moment.
[Josh] Looks beautiful. Nice and green,
very well proved. This is all good.
I'm actually just gonna
stick it back in for a bit longer.
It's not quite stretchy enough.
All the bread dread.
So, I'm doing a farmyard party.
It's basically how I remember my parties.
I'm sure my parents remember them
as being stressful,
with a lot of, like, six-year-olds
running around, high on sugar.
But, erm, I remember them being great.
[Noel] Tasha's farmyard buffet
celebrates parties from her childhood
with sweet choux bun lambs
filled with blackberry crème diplomat,
raspberry and pistachio biscuit
wagon wheels,
and after taking Star Baker in Bread Week,
she hopes to play to her strengths
with za'atar and sumac milk bread pigs.
[Tasha] Bread Week was great for me,
but this is the Bake Off
and I don't wanna get complacent.
[Matty] Cupcakes are done.
We're onto the doughnuts
which I already regret deciding to do
'cause they need to prove twice.
Biscuits are done. So I'm gonna
move on to my ankylosaurus teacakes.
[Cristy] This is the candy cane twists.
When done, they'll look good
'cause they're twisted
with the white dough.
[Josh] I've got pesto, fresh tomato,
sundried tomatoes
and some cheese for the couronne.
Gonna get these shaped,
they need to be proved and then baked.
Have you learnt a lot from the tent?
Yeah, I've learnt loads.
I've followed Paul for a long time.
When you say you've followed Paul,
do you mean online?
I've followed him
on Bake Off and obviously,
er, with his books and things.
Yeah, sort of tailgating his car.
-I sometimes get in his glove box.
-[laughs]
He reaches in there for a Marlboro
and I go, "Ah!" And he's like, "Ahhh!"
[Alison laughs]
Bakers, you are halfway through.
[Tasha] I'm behind time.
They needed to be proving ages ago.
[Noel] Do you want a feel?
-I like the big one.
-[both chuckling]
[Dan] In you go, kidda.
[Cristy] Get my pies in.
"Anything But Beige." That's a hell
of a title, isn't it, for a buffet?
[Dan] Half an hour at 180.
[Paul] We've got curries from Dan again.
He's doing about six things.
I'd rather he does three
and smashes it out of the park
than six which are adequate.
[Dan] These are gonna be
for my dinosaur eggs.
Some are more simple than others,
maybe he'll pull it off.
He sometimes does.
[Tasha] I'm making choux pastry now
for my choux lambs.
Tasha and Dan are always
the ones who are most ambitious.
[sighs] I've gotta get
an absolute wriggle on.
[Josh] They're in at 180
for about 20 minutes.
[Prue] Josh is back at Christmas.
The couronne idea with the spinach,
it may look okay.
I'm concerned
about the flavour being bland.
[Josh] Snowmen macarons.
Just wanted to show
some more skills with these.
[Matty] 170 for 25 minutes.
I think when you look at Matty,
fairly straightforward.
[Matty] What's next? Erm, macarons.
-Matty looks quite organised.
-He does, actually.
[Cristy] It's the meringue for the top
of the little lemon meringue pies.
-And Cristy, I love her Willy Wonka theme.
-[laughs] Yeah.
-Yes.
-[Prue] She's got a good idea.
The only danger is overcomplicating them
and therefore messing them up.
At this stage of the quarter-finals,
starting to whittle it down
and it's getting
more complicated to judge this.
♪ Running round the tent
Running round the tent ♪
♪ Running round, running round
Bakers, you have one hour left
of this party.
This is outrageous.
We're gonna kick you out in an hour.
We have to go to bed,
gotta get some sleep.
[Josh] Getting tighter on time now.
-[Tasha] Pig breads in the oven.
-[Dan] What am I doing? Anybody know?
I'm now gonna
get the ankylosaurus teacakes filled.
[Matty] Pies are demoulded.
Erm, macarons are in.
They need 14 minutes,
so we're onto the doughnuts.
Couple of minutes each side.
I just go by sight.
Never used a deep fat fryer though.
[Josh] I'm pleased with the bread,
nice and green.
Fifteen minutes for the macarons.
Gonna quickly make the ganache
and get the jam on now for those.
[Cristy] I hope my twists
are all right, they're in there.
I've just gotta not look.
Let 'em do their thing.
I'm just gonna roll up the Swiss roll now.
It's a big bake, isn't it?
This is a big one.
-It's too big for me.
-[Alison] You decided to do a dinosaur.
-I know. Yeah.
-It was your idea.
It was. And it was my idea
to do loads of things with it.
-[beeps]
-What's that?
-Is that my two minutes up?
-Yep.
My God, are these your dinosaur feet?
Look at this! They're the best.
[Dan] I think I've done everything
in terms of baking things.
[Tasha] I'm behind time.
I need to catch up.
[Noel] Bakers, you have
half an hour left.
You've had four hours.
-They're only making one cupcake.
-[laughing]
[Josh] There's a lot to do.
Decorating snowman time now.
[Dan] Done. It's good 'cause the egg wash
makes them look a bit scaly.
It's pretty cool.
The lemon meringues are in the oven so I'm
just making the little toadstool toppers.
[Matty] Going in with the orange curd.
Conscious that they'll say it's a cupcake
and this is the quarter-final.
So, it's a cupcake with curd.
[Tasha] Choux didn't rise.
There's no air in it.
It's as dense as a brick.
All my elements are done.
Need to start rocking and rolling now.
Need to get a move on,
I need to brûlée them as well.
[Josh] I want to fill the choux buns now
which'll form Christmas puddings.
Bakers, you've got 15 minutes left.
[exhales] Okay, that's going in.
[Cristy] Just covering
the back of the lollies.
It's a bit messy.
[Matty] They're gonna be tennis balls.
[Josh] This is just white chocolate.
[Dan] I'm putting a walnut on top
of the head, like an ankylosaurus armour
and then just a couple of fondant horns.
[Matty] This is the hardest I've worked.
Biscuit Week, I had to do a fair bit.
[Dan] I've never
worked harder to make food
and I probably never will do
once this chaos finishes.
[Tasha] My jam didn't set.
Tractor wheels will be rough. [sighs]
Bakers, you have one minute left.
[Matty] Assemble.
Okay, bakers, your time is up.
[both laughing]
[Matty] They don't look like
cricket balls, but I'm happy it's done.
It all looks a bit beige. I tried my best.
Oh, God, that was insane.
[Alison] The bakers'
Anything But Beige buffets
now face the judgement of Paul and Prue.
Cristy, tell us all
about your non-beige buffet.
So, I've got Swiss roll lollipop,
cheese and rosemary twists,
spicy beef and onion patties
and then lemon meringue pies.
It's a bit rough and ready.
I know. [chuckles]
[Paul] Everything has got flaws.
You look at the canes,
they are pretty rough.
Tastes okay, but it's not baked enough.
It's a pity, because I love the flavour.
[Paul] Okay, shall we try the pies?
-[Prue] They're meant to represent sweets?
-Yeah. And they're spicy.
[Prue] Mmm.
-I love that, tastes great.
-[Prue] I think that's delicious.
-Oh, okay, good.
-[Prue] So, those are the savoury ones?
Yes. This is lemon meringue.
[Prue] Proper lemon meringue pie taste.
[Paul] Comes down to the look.
Not the best-looking thing I've seen.
[Prue] A little uneven.
It's Willy Wonka, guys,
it's gotta be a bit uneven.
[Cristy chuckles]
It's lovely soft cake, I like the flavour.
-I think all your flavours are lovely.
-That's good.
Everything else,
when it comes to the visual effect,
-it has fallen short of what we expect.
-I agree.
[Prue] Matty, tell us all
about your showstopper.
[Matty] We've got
a cricket ball curry pie,
a orange cupcake golf course,
lime curd macarons
and some crème brûlée
doughnut basketballs.
[Paul] I like the colours,
few different colours in there.
Your little pies look pretty good.
They look pretty uniform.
[Prue] Matty, I think that you've
achieved something quite clever.
You've got a different-looking finish
on every one of them.
[Paul] Okay, let's try doughnuts.
-Very lovely shiny caramel, isn't it?
-[Paul] Yeah.
They taste of crème brûlée
so you can have that.
Oh, no.
-Your oil's too hot.
-Okay.
And because your oil's too hot,
it's a little raw inside.
The flavours are good.
The texture's not good.
[Paul] Bit uneven, these.
-[Prue] Lovely colour.
-[Paul] Nice shine.
-Nice flavour.
-[Prue] That curd is so delicious.
Really lovely.
Right, cricket balls.
[Matty] Cricket ball pies, yes.
-That's delicious, really nice.
-Thank you.
-[Paul] Then you have…
-[Matty] It's a chocolate orange cupcake.
There's a little bit of orange curd
in there too.
It's a lovely flavour.
It works well, a nice sharpness
coming from that orange,
quite a moist sponge that as well.
You got your flavours right
on most things,
your textures are slightly off.
-Okay.
-[Paul] Certainly on your doughnuts.
Your flavours have been pretty good.
-[Prue] Well done.
-Thank you.
Tasha, tell us all
about your buffet, please.
So this is my farmyard party.
I've made milk bread,
er, pigs and blackberry
crème diplomat choux
and pistachio and raspberry-flavoured
Viennese whirls
with a raspberry and peach jam.
Some of these things look quite nice.
I love the little pigs.
The Viennese whirls are underbaked.
-As you pick 'em up, they fall apart.
-Yeah.
But the flavour is absolutely perfect.
Oh, okay.
Hmm, that's quite disappointing.
[Paul] Hmm.
Yeah, underwhelming.
Let's have a look at these pigs.
Nice, er, structure inside.
The pigs are lovely. I like the texture,
I like the crust on them.
-You are such a good bread maker.
-Thank you.
[Paul] Overall, a little underwhelmed.
And they are a bit beige,
which was banned.
[chuckles]
Dan, tell us about your showstopper.
So, this is my prehistoric buffet
with chicken curry dinosaur feet,
lemon biscuit fossils,
strawberry marshmallow ankylosaurus
and then some dinosaur eggs
with vanilla mousse.
[Paul] I do like the theme.
Everything looks neat and tidy.
It's ambitious. A lot of stuff going on.
-[Paul] Shall we try the feet.
-[Prue] Dinosaur feet.
The curry is lovely.
The pastry is very crumbly
and actually delicious, but it's very dry.
[sighs]
-[Paul] Love the flavour, love the idea.
-[Prue] Hmm.
[Paul] Erm, shall we try fossil,
erm, lemon biscuits?
Very nice biscuit. Erm, it is beige.
[Paul] Let's have a look
at these chocolate fellas.
[Prue] The flavour's
overwhelmingly chocolate.
You hardly get the middle,
because the chocolate's thick.
This is an authentic egg.
-[Paul] That's very good.
-Very clever. You did six things.
Perhaps, if you'd done four things,
you could've got them perfect.
[Paul] Josh, tell us all about
your non-beige buffet.
We have got some
Christmas wreath couronnes,
then you've got choux buns
as my Christmas puddings
and then the snowmen macarons.
They're neat as a pin, they're uniform.
[Prue] Your little snowmen
are perfectly piped.
They're absolutely lovely.
[Paul] The couronne look nice, even,
quite tricky to do so small.
Mmm.
Delicious, actually, really soft,
it's well baked.
[Prue] It's got a crust to it
and soft in the middle.
-I think they work in looks and flavour.
-They're delicious.
[Paul] We've had the savoury.
They've got a caramel-like pastry
crème custard going through those.
That's absolutely delicious.
-The vanilla level in there is lovely.
-[Prue] Very, very silky filling.
[Paul] These are the coconut?
Yes, coconut and white chocolate ganache
and a jam right in the centre.
Mmm. Well, I love 'em.
Josh, I think you've done well.
It's hard to fault anything.
You've done well with the flavours.
It's something I would go back for.
-These are a triumph.
-[Prue] Aren't they?
-These are particularly good.
-Thanks.
-[Paul] Well done.
-[Josh] Thank you.
That was amazing, really chuffed.
My favourite comment
was Paul with the couronne.
To hear any comment like that
from Paul, king of bread, that's amazing.
I will take that with me forever.
I'd say this is the most positive
I've felt after any showstopper,
so I'm pretty happy.
If I hadn't come first in the technical,
I would be really anxious right now.
I'm pleased they liked all the flavours,
so I'm just gonna focus on that.
[Dan] General feeling is,
I think I'm bouncing around
between third and fifth.
Could be any one
of three of us to be honest.
How do you think
the showstopper went, Prue?
Who's gonna be reaching the semifinals?
If you look at that whole display,
they did get the idea of colour
and some of the things were so delicious
and some were so disappointing.
Let's look at Cristy,
'cause those patties,
you really liked those.
[Paul] The problem with Cristy's
is the way that it looks.
It's not polished enough.
I thought Josh did very well.
His couronne were delicious.
So, there's a couple of people
I think in line for Star Baker.
-I think Matty is in line.
-Matty.
I do think Josh is there.
-What, for Star Baker, Josh?
-Yeah.
But he had a particularly
bad day yesterday, didn't he?
Whereas, Matty got a handshake.
Matty had a decent day yesterday.
He could be one to watch.
But Josh had the good sense
to just do three things
and do them exquisitely.
-Whereas Dan on the other hand--
-Dan did everything.
[Prue] Has he done enough to survive?
Cristy's another one that could go,
so it's between those two.
It's so sad, I can't believe
we've got to that stage
-where two really good bakers are here.
-Two Star Bakers.
Gotta send a Star Baker home.
-I know.
-They've all been Star Baker.
Well done, bakers, you really
did bring the party to the tent.
I've got the great job of announcing
this week's Star Baker.
And the Star Baker is…
Matty.
Thank you.
Unfortunately, I've got the horrible job
of announcing
who's leaving the tent today.
The baker needs to know
that when you get to this stage,
you have done so, so well.
And we're really,
really sad to see them go.
The baker leaving the tent today is…
Cristy.
-So sorry.
-No, it's okay.
[Prue] Cristy,
you've done so well, honestly.
I'm so sorry to see Cristy go
because she cares so much
and she is a really good baker.
-[Paul] Well done, Cristy.
-Thank you.
It's been such a crazy,
fast-paced experience.
So, now I can sit back and reflect
on what an amazing time I've had.
[chuckling]
I'm really proud to have got this far,
really proud.
-Well done, Matty.
-[Matty] Thank you, Prue.
I wasn't expecting that.
I had a pretty perfect week
with the handshake, the Star Baker.
I am happy for Matty.
He just, just pipped Josh
to take Star Baker.
It was really because he did fantastic
sausage rolls yesterday.
-Lara.
-[Lara over mobile] Yeah.
-I won Star Baker.
-[screaming] Oh, my God!
[laughs]
I hope this gives me the confidence
that maybe I needed
knowing what I'm up against next week
and hopefully beyond.
Semifinals. [laughs]
Paul said "lucky." [laughs]
But I'll take lucky.
[Alison] Come on, group hug.
Bring the party. Yay!
[closing theme music playing]